it's a good start isn't it
good morning everyone start again um I'm
councel David Curtis and I'm indebted to
Olivia Quinn who has reminded me to turn
my microphone on she's here from
democratic services to support the panel
uh I'm chairing the panel this morning
and I'd like the other members of the
panel to introduce
themselves good morning I'm counc Sarah
Wy
hoggins and good morning I'm cancelan
shenton
and we also have going round the
table Vicky Goodman licensing
officer thank you very much and we also
have
Mr Mr Amit is it man from the and you
are the applicant yeah I am the
applicant sir thank you very
much Vicki would you like to introduce
the item then thank you I will chair if
you could just bear with me I was just
logged into the Open Session to share a
couple of pictures but it's just throw
me out so I'm just going to try and go
back in before I
start
there we go thank you
panel I'm sorry Vicki can I just say um
we have no apologies for of no apologies
um but can I just check that we have any
Declarations of interest in the
panel no
no thank you chair so um you are here to
determine an application for a new
premises license for shipston pizza and
fried
chicken excuse me um the premises um are
located located on West Street which is
in shipston on sta and a location plan
can be viewed on page five of my
report um you'll see on that page that
it shows the premises as a blacked out
rectangular shaped building which as you
can see is just off the main High Street
with the b435 to the west and the a3400
to the east and south um so they're
situated on that sort of oneway system
within shipston um to insist there are
some pictures from Google Maps which is
on the screen for you these show that
there are two entrances to the um
business one at the front and one to the
side which leads to a car park which
facilitates um a number of other
businesses in that
vicinity the application was submitted
at the end of November during the
consultation period we've received two
formal and relevant objections which the
application means that it needs to be
determined by the panel which is before
you
today whilst the applicant has chosen to
submit an application for a new premises
I would like to point out um for
clarification that there is another
license in place already in existence
for um the business which permits the
provision of late night refreshment on a
Friday and Saturday between the hours of
2300 and
midnight a copy of this license is
contained within my report on pages 7 to
on this license I would draw um your
attention to the three conditions um and
they're shown on page
nine um I only do this because if you're
minded to um Grant the application today
um there would effectively be another
license issued so there would be two
separate licenses in place running sort
of concurrently now the applicant does
have the option to um surrender one one
of the licenses once there's two
licenses in place um so you may want to
um get a steer in in that regard um and
that would obviously be of course only
if they continue to pay the annual fee
on both
licenses Vicki can I just check that the
um this these conditions would apply to
both
licenses um so they wouldn't so which
was the reason for me drawing your
attention to it so if you're minded to
Grant a license today you may want to
consider copying those or that those
conditions coming over onto this new
license as
well uh Additionally you may notice that
the current license shows that it's been
recently issued this is um correct and
for further Clarity this is because the
license has been recently um transferred
and that was following an application to
transfer the premises hold order to uh
Mr ISAT who's here
today um so um back to the matter in
hand which is the application before you
today which seeks to allow late night
refreshment on a Friday and Saturday
from 2300 hours until
0030 um on all of the days they've said
that they will close at 2300 hours um
and it's only the provision of hot food
or drink between the hours of 2300 hours
and 5 um that fall within the remit of
Licensing so it's it's only the days
they seek to pay to trade past 11 that
require a license so effectively it is
sort of an extension of 30 minutes on
both of those
days so as with all applications the
applicant must set out how they intend
to promote the four licensing objectives
um they do that um as part of the
application um which um um you can view
on page 20 of the report and you'll note
that the applicant has said that they
intend on having
CCTV um warning notices an incident book
um that the license Holder will ensure
that all staff receive appropriate
training about emergency and general
safety precautions that first aid
equipment and materials must be
available on the premises that they will
have le legible notices requesting
people leave the premises quietly to be
displayed um and then um it does go on
to talk about underrated sale notices
refusals register um and training as
such um but I suspect that this is
perhaps um not the case as there isn't
any alcohol being sold or anything that
I'm aware of that is age related sales
um again I'm sure the applicant would be
able to offer some clarification on that
um whilst those conditions are um have
been put forward the CCTV if you're
minded to Grant you know um to say that
they would have CCTV we really like to
perhaps drill down on that a bit more so
the length of time that they would have
it they would keep it for um and some
other sort of requirements in in that
respect um during the consultation
period we received two formal and
relevant objections to this application
um unfortunately neither could attend
today's meeting but they have asked me
asked me to read out their
representations um so the first one is
from Miss Jones um who lives on 11 West
Street which um on the map just on the
screen um shows uh Granville court and
number two is where the um
takeaway is located number 11 you can
see is just slightly opposite on the
opposite side of the road and just to
explain the um plan on the right hand
side of of that picture is um I suppose
a layout of the building which is
[Music]
um Bond
house bongate house so they they're sort
of a um one sort of tiny um section of
that big building that you can see and
then the green area is is the car park
that I referred to earlier which sort of
um is used by other businesses within
that location so I think you can just
see on there that there's a Red Line
outlining the um the
business sort of in the middle of the
bottom if not we I can point that
out uh no it's not actually it's you
would only see it on the screen so I can
I can try and zoom in on that in
a just go back to miss
Jones's sorry go
on sorry I do actually know this
location really well
and I know that those car parking spaces
that we refer to are not just for
businesses they are also for the
residents that are living above the
premises where your takeaway is as well
it's a sort of a it's it's it's not just
the businesses that have the car parking
there there is residents car parking I
believe for the those those if to look
at the map that we've got here if you
look at
um these car park yeah all those car
parking spaces are also not all of them
designated car parking the residences at
1 2 7 it's um they they're above Flats
but I just wanted to make that that
because that sort of gives an idea that
there's lots of car parking in that area
and there certainly isn't thank
you thank you so yeah as I was saying um
we've had um an objection of um the
person that lives at number 11 which is
um on the the opposite side of the road
um I will read out their
objection I object to the application of
Late Night opening for the following
reasons large groups of people up to F
40 at its worth gathered outside the
takeaway after the pubs have closed they
are drunk extremely noisy and at times
aggressive towards each other fights
have broken out and people have been
pushed against my house this antisocial
Behavior often goes on after 1: a.m.
there have been incidents of people
being sick down my window and urinating
against the house I live directly
opposite the premises the bedrooms are
at are on the front of the house
therefore I cannot escape the noise my
job requires me to work weekends I am up
at 6:00 a.m. and on regular occasions do
14 days in a row since the takeaway has
stuck to 11:00 p.m. closing there have
been no incidents of large Gatherings or
antisocial Behavior I live by myself and
find the aforementioned Behavior
intimidating
the second objection was from uh seven
West Street which is next door to number
11 again on the opposite side of the
road um I will read that objection which
is as a disabled resident having lived
here since
1994 I object to any proposed extension
of license my objection being large
groups of noisy people Gathering
opposite me eating and generally
disturbing the piece
I realize that young people have nowhere
to go after the pub shut and it is an
easy place to convene but this is a
residential area we are allowed our
peace and rest without disturbance I
have witnessed young men urinating and
defecating on the premises of the three
used calf the owners do not come out
after they close and pick up rubbish
which is left in all the years I have
lived here I have never seen such filth
I realize that some people find The
Establishment an asset to the town I
have no objection to the takeaway itself
I have complained many times to the Town
Council over the past month and recently
they have been abiding by the laws if an
extension is granted to the opening
hours I will have to tolerate sleepless
nights noise urinating a lack of rubbish
collection and takeaway delivery service
cars being parked on double yellow lines
causing traffic jams late at night
coming from London Road as Lor's cannot
turn I would be very grateful if the
council could make sure that the license
is not granted enabling me to get my
very needed rest if you would like to
check with shipston Medical Center on my
disabilities I give me give my consent
um I've just read that out in its
entirety so um that was the second um
objection uh in addition to the two
objections we did receive a number of
emails in support of the application um
however only one gave their consent for
their details and comments to be um
provided to today's panel um it's only
right and fair that I also read that
out bear with me as I put my hand on
it that was from a Julian Morris um of
lower Street Dennis Farm hunington I
wish to make a representation to the
licensing committee to support the
reinstatement of a license for provision
of late night refreshment to Mr Amma
iset Mr iset isn't and his excellent
team provide a very friendly and popular
takeaway food service in our town and as
such they are very much part of our
community they work extremely hard and I
believe they are highly valued in
shipston so to recap panel the um
application before you is one of
um uh them seeking to provide late night
refreshment on a Friday and Saturday
night between the hours of 2300 and
in coming to your decision you have the
following
options which is having regards to all
of the
representations um you can um Grant the
license subject to the conditions
mentioned in the operating schedule
which can be modified to such an extent
as a local Authority considers
appropriate for the promotion of the
licensing
objectives um you can exclude from the
scope of the license any of the license
services to which the application
relates um or you can reject um whole or
the whole or part of the application
before you
today that concludes
my rund down of the application thank
you Vicki um I think just yesterday you
mentioned another objection had been
received do you have that available
apologies yes so Mr Jenkins of number 7
um submitted some further comments let
me just put my hand on
those
is this just for clarification is this
one of the same object so it's the same
objector but the same objector but he
wanted um a couple of further sentences
to be read out which you have just
reminded
me these for the benefit of everyone
else these were circulated
yesterday so everyone has already seen
them so um Mr Jenkins asked for the
following to be added to his
objection um who will these extended
hour opening hours attract people
leaving the pubs this could mean that
the groups that gather will be there
even later causing a disturbance as they
don't go home and there is nowhere else
for them to go as it is there can as it
is there can be there can be noise and
antisocial Behavior past 1:00 if the
opening hours are extended this would
also mean car door slamming later at
night if people are hungry they will
order their food food before the
takeaway
closes thank
you Vicki you mentioned we've got um two
there would be if we Grant this
application we'd end up with two
licenses um and given that the uh
postcode on the one license is different
to the postcode on this
application um can we tidy that up or
should or or can that only be done if we
sort of revoke one
and combine into the new
license I think the on the one it says 4
HD on the other one it says 4
a
cv36
um yes that can be done um I think it's
a matter of our internal mapping system
shows that as the address um I'm not
aware that it's a
different area within that building um
so yeah we can we can certainly um tie
that up so that they they are the
same
so just to summarize this application
before us today is this is we are merely
asking or we are ask the applicant is
asking for two for half an hour extra in
on top of the license he's already got
he just wants an additional half an hour
on these uh on the on the license is
that is that right for two for two for
the for the two late nights already
Friday and satday so just 30 minutes on
each late night is that is that correct
that is correct thank
you sorry can I just clarify this is a
separate application that the applicants
made for a new license effectively does
amount to an extension on the existing
license but he's applying for a new
license it's a separate issue so you're
considering the license as a whole with
those additional half and hours so it's
not an extension application it's a new
application yeah now I I understand that
I was just trying to get the differences
between one and another so the
difference is the difference is half an
hour two nights a week effectively thank
you thank you for the clarification over
the license and I think we understand
that but question does it make a
substantive difference is is there a
substantive difference in what we're
actually considering
today
so if you were considering modifying if
it was an application to extend the
hours on the existing license the
options available to you would be
different because you'd already have a
license in place and so what you could
do in respect to that license would
differ to now that you're considering a
fresh license you can reject the entire
application not just the hours as
requested but you can effectively reject
the entire application because it's a
new application but just to be clear the
objections that we've had have been not
to the existing not to the new license
it's purely as I understand to those to
the extension on those two nights I
think Vicki can clarify but the
consultation process was in respect of
the applica the new application for the
new license yes and so it's a odd
situation because you already had an
operating premises with business there
and so the residents of million with it
but this is a new
application so Vicki can I just check
sorry if I'm see seeming pantic the
objections that we've received appear to
only relate to the extension on those
two nights in the new application we
haven't had any
objections as I understand
to the the to to the current sort of
operation
it's it is the object to the to the
extension
ours
so both have objected to the application
that's in so the application that's in
and before you today is for late night
refreshment between 11: and 0030 yeah
they just sort of going back over their
comments they they haven't sort of said
that they're
happy with the existing hours um they
they have sort of merely just commented
on the application that's before them
which I think Aller is saying that
legally you have to take that as an
objection towards the the application in
its entirety so the panel today is
considering the new application not the
existing license that's in place just
the new
application thank
you on the the the subject of the um of
the the objections have we had anything
well have they first of all the police
have they they're aware of this
application and the Town Council I guess
should be aware of it have we have we
had we still have no representations
from them or any indication as to
whether these uh comments about
disturbances and that have been are
actually on a log at the police they
have I suppose the simple question is
how have they been in touch with us in
any
way okay yeah so to confirm the um
police are a statutory consult te so
they very much have had the application
and they've made no comment on it um the
Town Council wouldn't be a statutary
consult um out of courtesy we um let
District counselors know of any
applications in their Ward um but we we
don't notify directly the Town Council
but we do advertise on our website any
application so so there would have been
that 28-day period where anybody could
have made a representation and that
hasn't happened the only representations
um that we've received are before you
today so did either um did councelor
hatch or councelor passingham make any
comments regarding this
application because those are the two uh
councilors for shipston
not that I'm aware of now thank
you thank you um Mr hman would you like
to make some make any comments about
this application
please yeah
hi uh when I get this premises out was I
uh thought about it was we got the
license till halfast 12 then I didn't
know the TR the the license can be the
transfer has to be under my name so we
didn't know so once we realize that we
haven't uh the the license is not under
my
name then I been we've been told by
straford Council and to have to transfer
you got to get the new license or you
have to transfer the new uh new
application for the
license then when I spoke to the pro
owners and he said he's got to license
it till until 12:00 when I see the old
licenses and I get transfer into the my
name then I'm operating till 12:00 at
the moment that's why we little bit
complicated for the two licenses one is
licenses up to 12:00 the new license is
halfast 12 that's the the complicated
from maybe the my agent who does the
application who who application that's
why we get a complicated it so I got my
license I can trade till midnight
12:00 on that is the with old ni old
license previous
license the the new license is
we make by uh make by accidentally or
not accidentally I mean unknown cuz I
thought this was the license previous
licenses is halfast till half1 12 that's
that's why we put the times on it that's
uh the main reason I don't know whether
I did expect or
not that's makes it too complicated on
it so you just said that you hadn't
actually realized that the old license
was until 12:00 only on those two nights
can I just ask you as you're here
are you actually bothered about that
additional half do you want it to be
will you be open till 12:30 why why I
know these things happen with with
numbers in boxes and agents working for
you do you anticip do you need that
license to be until 12:30 to to be
honest it's not Madam if I knew is that
uh T I can trade till uh 12:00 I won't
bother to you to come to hear the
wasting your times and all this then I
is I can only blame for my agent who
does my application and he didn't inform
me about it
Madam so yes I'm just sorry do you want
this license because we can just sort it
out here do you want this license to be
until 12:30 on those two nights because
that's really what everybody's I I
understand but but it's to be honest not
Madam so I I'm happy with till 12:00 as
it
is I'm so sorry that's the that's this
why I came but it's it's not me I I just
been informed it
yesterday to be honest I it's I'm so
sorry about that's all
yeah other ways
yeah a question to do with this then
have you been trading till 12:30 pardon
me have have you been trading in the
meantime till 12:30
no so your
website says that says that you're
opening hours until 12:30 on Friday and
Saturday so why is that that's what uh
because the when I previous owner told
me we got the we can trade till weekends
Friday and Saturday till half1 12 that's
why we put that times on it when I
didn't know I didn't realize that until
you tell you tell me that I will change
that time on on the website and I'm
opening the since since as soon as I get
my since I get my the the SEC license
the new license previously I get it I'm
trading till 12:00 on those two
night and I can change that time because
I didn't realize that I will check that
today and I will change
it so whilst we're on the subject then
of of the website M there's a couple of
other um issues that I I have with that
because I think on Thursday it says
you're trading from 7 a.m. in the
morning um and it's got
the um the address as been in werer been
in Worcester forgate Street can you tidy
those up so at least all what you your
license on your website at least look
the same you know I I I will check that
up but I'm not very keen about those the
websites and all this I'm not very keen
about it but I will check that I will
sort that things out
Madam just wondering if we should take a
brief adjournment to get some to clarify
some legal advice on the best now given
the understanding that we have that
we're now looking at an application for
Mid to midnight on the Friday and
Saturday and it seems to be that we're
looking at regularizing things rather
than changing could we just take an
adjournment for just a brief adjournment
for 10 minutes while we get some advice
would that
be so don't go away we should we just go
into another room for 10 minutes we'll
just adjourn for 10 minutes if you just
like to wait but I think it would it
would be helpful for the panel to to get
some advice at this point if it
clarifies things your in respect of the
current application that's before you
yeah applicant has just indicated that
he doesn't actually want that license so
you might want to invite him to withdraw
that application now before you the
other aspects I think the questions with
the existing license they're not really
something for you to be dealing with at
the moment that would be something to be
dealt with by the licensing team as an
administrative process so in respect of
the application before you that's the
option
we'll just adjourn for 10 minutes just
so we can really understand exactly what
we're all up all doing thank you very
much thank you for your
patience
thank you all for your patience I think
we've got some verification now um so um
Mr isitman
the suggestion or proposal we have is
that you have an existing license in
place that you should
withdraw this current application for
the new license that will have no
bearing on your ability to
trade as you you wish and Alla if you
could give some advice think would be
helpful clarify it's up to you whether
you want to continue with this
application so the panel at the moment
the application before them to consider
is for the new license with the
operating hours on the Friday and the
Saturday up until half past midnight so
it's up to you given the indication
you've given to the panel that you
aren't so concerned about the hours
going up until half past midnight do you
want to to consider with this applica do
you want to continue with this
application or do you want to withdraw
it that's in respect of the new
application it has nothing to do with
the existing license that's already in
place I can I can withdraw this license
if it's not affecting my the LI previous
license no that's it the previous
license it's up to you can continue with
this new application it's up to you
you've you can have the panel make a
decision on that but it's well I I got I
got to respect my neighbors as well they
might be helping them to cut that half
an hour then make maybe make difference
for them
so I can
be stick till stay with till 12:00 it's
on half an hours it w't make any
difference to me if it make anything
different to them they might be helpful
keep happy my neighbors
so can I just say that do you know what
that's quite refreshing to have such an
honorable kind of applicant sitting here
so thank you very much indeed for for
clarifying that and for taking heed of
of the effect that those additional um
half an hours would have I think that
that's all I'd like to say over to you
thank you
so um you're agreeing to withdraw this
new
application um all i' would like to say
is to be if and you you clearly wish to
be a good neighbor and as my colleague
says that's that's extremely refreshing
um but if you can be mindful of the
conditions of the transfer license um
the
CCTV the incident and all of that and
I'm sure as you wish to be a good
neighbor you'll take all those things in
into account do we have any further
comments
no Vicki
No thank you very much thank you for
your patience giving us that time to get
some
clarification thank
you you have no urgent
business
Vicki oh
sorry just just a point of clarification
does Mr sorry the name again Mr isman
need to
say clearly that he will he wishes to
withdraw this application I think that
would be best can you Mr confirm that
you are withdrawing this application
currently before the panel yes I am
withdrawing my
application thank you Mr
urgent business um I declare the meeting
closed at 10:15 thank you all very much
for your
time